we had an outfit change outfit change
yeah I had to get rid of the Revenge
dress I was over it was it was it called
the Revenge dress it's time to move on
so like you get did you get revenge
tonight no no absolutely not
um but it was good I mean it was it was
a nice start to being able to kind of
like share my story yeah yeah I mean I
know that there was I mean we'll just
jump right into it you know talking
about Paul's comment about you not being
the mother of his kids I struggled with
um
at least in terms of envisioning Micah
as like you know a mother I think for me
it was like difficult for me to do I
know you guys hash that out but did that
provide any closure to you or did it
seem to create more questions for you or
is it now that you guys are you're a
year past this relationship now it's
it's done like you don't need to worry
about this anymore yeah I think it was
it did create a little more confusion
for me going into tonight I was kind of
under the impression that
you know he didn't mean it like that
like that's kind of what he was feeding
me before I got out there and his
response didn't really necessarily add
up like that for me so it's a little bit
hurtful I think honestly watching back
the last episode was hard for me I think
I've always kind of held a little place
in my heart that maybe there was a
future for Paul and I and after hearing
that not only is there obviously not but
there kind of never was and I feel a
little duped
but you know
it's fine I think
growing moving on and moving forward is
kind of what's on the horizon so do you
feel like you need to have another
conversation with him or no that's
that's done
I don't need it here anymore it's okay I
I want him to be happy I want to be
happy I think we've said what what we're
gonna say yeah do you feel like tonight
you were you were able to say what you
wanted to say and basically watching
your own actions over again do you feel
at peace with your experience on the
show now I feel a little bit at peace I
think there's a lot more to say you know
there's you know there's things I want
to explain
um that I didn't get the chance to I
think there's just so much to talk about
that I didn't get to say everything I
wanted to but you know eventually I'll
have that chance and that's fine with me
yeah anything you want to say right now
is there like a is there like a you know
a bullet point that you wanted to say
that you didn't get the chance to I
think there's a few things I think one
thing that stands out a lot though is I
never really got to kind of own up to my
part and you know the Irina and I
situation I wish I could have talked a
bit more about that I wanted to explain
some of the back story with Amber and I
I wanted to explain you know how I
didn't know that she was crying but I
still feel like I needed to own up for
being maybe insensitive I didn't I was
worried like did he did he break up with
her or not and I didn't I didn't really
care how she was feeling that moment but
when she did Round the Corner I gave her
a huge hug when I realized she was
crying it was heartbreaking and I felt
terrible for being so insensitive we
also had Zach come out and say that he
didn't think that you were gonna marry
Paul regardless you guys you were not
there to find love but perhaps maybe
Fame
I mean nobody knows what was going on in
you except for you how do you feel like
that's is that accurate do you feel like
that's inaccurate I feel like his
comment was so out of left field I don't
even want to give it the time of day I
don't know where that came from no one
wanted to own up to saying that because
probably no one said it I think that he
was making a lot of comments to hurt
other people
during the entire thing I don't
understand but
it's not my business it's not true
[Applause]
love is a we are sorry we're late we are
no longer live but we are now finally
here yes
knowing what you were in for and then
we're going live at five o'clock and
then five o'clock comes and you're not
live and five o'clock becomes six
o'clock what was going on in your mind
between five and six were you like like
a boxer ready to fight who was then like
told nope back to the dressing room for
an hour yeah I was just anxious I just
wanted to I wanted to get things off my
chest I wanted to be able to have that
conversation with everyone and I just I
honestly I just wanted to get it over
with like I wanted to have everyone you
know be able to say their piece and so I
was a little anxious but it happens
anybody say why it was because
yeah I don't know I mean the show's been
a huge
a huge mess like drama social media I'm
not shocked that of course it ended in
some sort of chaos like that but
thanks so much Mike I really appreciate
it nice chatting
foreign